[S01] 你有没有过这样的经历，就是呃你正盯着手机屏幕，准备抢那张你梦寐以求的演唱会门票，或者是限量版的球鞋
[S02] 肯定有啊，倒计时一结束，手就开始狂点付款
[S01] 对，你疯狂点击付款按钮，结果呢屏幕上那个代表加载的小圈圈就开始无休止地转动
[S02] 那一瞬间真的是心都提到了嗓子眼儿
[S01] 没错，然后出于本能，你肯定就开始疯狂地刷新页面，狂点再次提交，那一刻你心里绝对在打鼓，哎呀，完了完了，我会被扣两次钱吗？票到底买到没有？
[S02] 确实是这样，我相信屏幕前的你肯定也体会过那种呃在数字世界里完全失去控制感的恐慌
[S01] 绝对的
[S02] 但有趣的是，什么说呢？很多时候哪怕你像疯了一样刷新了十几次，你的银行卡依然只扣了一次钱，而且那张票也依然稳稳的躺在你的账户里
[S01] 哎，这其实并不是因为你运气好，对吧？
[S02] 没错，这不是运气，这是因为在那个旋转的小圈圈背后，其实有一群全球顶尖的工程师，设计了一套极度强韧的数据系统
[S01] 哇，所以欢迎你加入我们今天的这趟探索之旅。不管你此刻是在抢票，还是在刷新信用卡账单，甚至是在地铁里断网的情况下疯狂刷着手机，你的每一次点击背后都有一套庞大混沌但极其精妙的数据架构在运转
[S02] 是的，一个极其庞大的系统
[S01] 我们今天的任务呢，就是为你拆解这个神奇的黑盒。不过在进入正题之前，我想先分享这次深度解析资料里的一句话，它真的瞬间击碎了我对于那种呃所谓完美系统的执念
[S02] 哦，是哪句话？
[S01] 是十三世纪的哲学家圣托马斯·阿奎那说过的一句话。他说，如果船长的终极目标是保护船只，他应该永远待在港口
[S02] 哇，这句话放在今天的数据系统架构里简直再贴切不过了
[S01] 对吧？
[S02] 我们总有一种幻想，就是想要打造一个完美无缺坚不可摧的数字堡垒，但现实是非常残酷的
[S01] 因为根本没有完美的系统
[S02] 对，完美无缺，不承担任何风险的系统是不存在的。一旦你的应用要面对真实的海量的用户，面对真实的网络波动，你的船就必须出海去迎接外面的狂风巨浪
[S01] 好了，那咱们就来拆解一下，既然船注定要出海，既然我们要处理真实世界里极其复杂的业务需求，我们到底该用什么工具呢？
[S02] 这是一个非常核心的问题
[S01] 因为呃传统观念可能会告诉你，哎，咱们就买最贵的功能最全的数据库，把所有的用户数据、订单、搜索记录全塞进去就完事了。
[S02] 很多人确实是这么想的。
[S01] 我们总幻想着存在一种全能型的神器。我其实挺好奇的，为什么我们不能借用一个超强的数据库搞定一切呢？比如关系型数据库，用那种高级的SQL语言，把所有复杂性都藏在底层
[S02] 听起来像是个好主意，对吧？
[S01] 对啊，开发者只要下达指令就行了。这听起来像是一个完美的独裁者，把一切打理得井井有条，但资料里似乎完全否定了这条路，反而推崇一九七零年代诞生的UNIX哲学
[S02] 确实是这样，这里有一个非常核心的理念冲突，关系型数据库确实想为你包揽一切，它就像一个全包式的豪华度假村
[S01] 哈哈，全包式度假村什么都有。
[S02] 但是在现代极其复杂的应用场景下，资料给出了一个非常明确的结论，那就是任何一种单一的数据模型能搞定所有的访问模式。
[S01] 等等，也就是全能数据库是个神话。
[S02] 没错，你想想在今天的一个复杂APP里，你需要存用户的支付记录，这要求极高的安全性，对吧？
[S01] 对，钱的事情不能马虎。
[S02] 然后你还需要对海量商品做拼音或者是模糊搜索，这又需要专门的搜索引擎。同时你还得把用户行为实时喂给机器学习模型去做推荐。
[S01] 确实，这些需求完全不一样。
[S02] 你指望一个全能数据库把这些全干了，而且全干得完美。这就好比指望一把瑞士军刀，既能用来砍断大树，又能用来做精密的外科心脏手术一样。
[S01] 哇，瑞士军刀的比喻太精准了，它确实什么都能干，但往往什么都干不到极致。那相比之下，UNIX哲学这么做的
[S02] UNIX崇尚的是极简和解耦，它提倡什么呢？不要去造那种庞大的机器，而是去做功能单一、极其锋利的小工具。
[S01] 也就是把大系统拆碎。
[S02] 对，然后用管道把它们连起来，这就是现代架构的演进方向，也是咱们今天资料里强调的一个核心趋势，叫做分拆数据库。
[S01] 我们不再寻找全能神了，而是把数据库直接大卸八块
[S02] 没错
[S01] 等一下，如果我把数据库大卸八块，保留一个专门做搜索的系统，一个专门做缓存的系统，还有一个做推荐的那它们之间怎么沟通？
[S02] 这是一个非常实际的问题。
[S01] 比如呃我改了我的用户头像，我怎么保证这三个系统里的头像都同时更新了，难道不会乱套吗？
[S02] 问得好，这里最令人着迷的地方就出现了，现代系统引入了异步事件日志来作为粘合剂。
[S01] 异步事件日志。
[S02] 对，你可以把它想象成整个系统的中枢神经，所有的数据变换，比如你刚才说的改了头像，都会变成一条绝对不可改变的事件，记录在这个日志里。
[S01] 哦，也就是所有的动作都被记下来了。
[S02] 没错，然后那些被拆分出来的专业系统，就像神经末梢一样，默默地盯身着这个日志，他们按照自己的节奏读取事件，然后更新自己的状态。
[S01] 哇，如果我们把这和更大的图景联系起来看，这不仅仅是让系统跑得更快了吧。
[S02] 你想到了什么？
[S01] 我觉得这简直是对人类协作方式的解放啊，因为这意味着负责搜索团队的工程师和负责缓存团队的工程师再也不用天天开会吵架了，对吧？
[S02] 哈哈，你看到了这背后极其重要的组织价值。确实，这种松散耦合的架构意味着不同团队可以完全独立的运作。
[S01] 这太重要了。
[S02] 哪怕搜索团队的服务器突然烧毁了，宕机了一个小时，也完全不会影响主数据库正常接单。事件日志会把那一小时的信息安全的缓存起来。
[S01] 等搜索服务器修好了，重启，再接着处理就行了。
[S02] 完全正确，互不干扰，这才让构建像今天这样拥有几万名工程师，服务几十亿用户的超大规模系统成为了可能。
[S01] 这正是真正有趣的地方。如果我们把数据库拆散了，所有的状态都在通过事件日志像水一样不断地向下游流动。这让我联想到了资料里提到了一个绝妙的类比。
[S02] 哪个类比？
[S01] 现代最前沿的数据流架构，本质上竟然是在模仿一九七九年诞生的WIZIKALK电子表格。
[S02] 啊，那个经典的电子表格。
[S01] 对，你想啊在ESL这样的电子表格里，你在A一单元格里输入一个新数字，旁边关联的求和公式，甚至是另一页的柱状图都会唰的一下自动刷新。
[S02] 没错，非常丝滑。
[S01] 今天这些高大上的现代应用不就是在做一样的事情吗？当你改变一个状态，下游所有的东西全跟着动了。
[S02] 这个类比非常直观。在复杂的系统架构中，这个概念被称为派生数据。
[S01] 派生数据就是衍生出来的意思吧。
[S02] 对，你的基础事实发生了变更，比如一笔新订单诞生，这就好比在电子表格里敲入了一个新数字。
[S01] 然后呢？
[S02] 这个动作会像涟漪一样，触发一系列下游函数的重新计算。比如更新库存的搜索索引，刷新用户的购物车缓存，甚至触发物流系统的分配逻辑。
[S01] 哇，牵一发而动全身。
[S02] 是的，这些下游产生的所有数据，其实都是从源头那笔订单日志派上出来的。
[S01] 呃，这里我得让你稍微停一下。说到刷新用户的购物车缓存，资料里提到了写路径和读路径的概念。
[S02] 嗯，这是个很关键的区别。
[S01] 这听起来有点抽象，它和刚才电子表格的类比有什么关系？
[S02] 我们可以这样理解，你敲击键盘修改单元格那一瞬间引发的一系列后台计算叫写路径。
[S01] 也就是输入数据的时候。
[S02] 对，而你眼睛看着屏幕上最终呈现出来的那个漂亮的图表叫读路径。在传统的系统里，读路径非常辛苦。
[S01] 怎么个辛苦法？
[S02] 用户每次想看图表，系统都要临时去把所有的原始数据翻出来，现场给你算一遍。
[S01] 那肯定很慢。
[S02] 所以现代系统引入了一个叫物化视图的概念。
[S01] 哎，术语警告，什么是物化视图？能不能用大白话解释一下？
[S02] 没问题。想象你去咖啡店点一杯极其复杂的特调咖啡，
[S01] 好的，我去买咖啡。
[S02] 传统做法是你点单后，咖啡师现场给你磨豆、打奶泡、调配糖浆，你要在柜台前等很久，这就是把压力放在了读路径上。
[S01] 因为是我要喝的时候才开始做。
[S02] 没错，而物化视图呢就像是咖啡师提前预判了你的需求。在你来之前，只要有新一批咖啡豆送达，也就是写路径更新了，他就立刻把这杯特调做出来，放在保温柜里。
[S01] 哇，这招聪明。
[S02] 等你真正来点单的时候，他直接把现成的咖啡递给你。我们其实是在用输入时的复杂计算，换取你读取时的极致速度。
[S01] 啊，提前做好放在保温柜里，这个解释太清晰了。这又完全解释了为什么现在很多手机APP，哪怕我在没有信号的地铁里依然能秒开页面，甚至还能点赞。
[S02] 对，因为你看到的不是实时的。
[S01] 其实我手机屏幕上显示的根本不是那一刻，从几千公里外的SERVER拉取的实时数据，对吧？
[S02] 完全正确，这就是现在非常流行的呃离线优先架构。
[S01] 离线优先。传统的模式是你点一下按钮，手机向服务器发请求，服务器算好再返回给你。但现在不同了，服务器只是把状态变更的事件流直接推送到你的手机里。
[S02] 也就是说，我的手机本身就是一个保温柜。
[S01] 没错，你的手机本身就是云端数据中心的一个物化试图缓存。即便你断网了，你依然在和本地这个保温柜交互。
[S02] 太绝了，那等我连上网呢？
[S01] 等你重新连上网，手机再把你在地铁里产生的那些点赞事件悄悄地退回给服务器。
[S02] 听起来这种像电子表格一样的数据流，配合本地缓存，体验确实顺滑无比。但是呃等等，我的直觉告诉我，这里面有个大问题。
[S01] 哦，什么问题？
[S02] 如果这种异步流动只是用来发发朋友圈或者点个赞，那肯定没问题。可如果涉及到钱呢？
[S01] 涉及到钱，事情就复杂了。
[S02] 对啊，就像咱们节目一开始说的那个场景，当我把系统拆散，全靠事件在不同系统间流动，而且网络还有可能断掉，我怎么保证我不会被扣两次钱？
[S01] 这是个非常典型的焦虑。
[S02] 我以前一直以为地层数据库里有一种叫ACID的事务机制，它就像一个宝箱箱一样，能保证原子性，就是要么全成功，要么全失败，难道它不能保护我免受这种双重扣款的倒霉事吗？
[S01] 哎，这就引出了一个非常重要的问题，也是很多资深工程师都容易陷入的错觉。
[S02] 数据。
[S01] 大家总以为只要花大价钱买一个足够昂贵、支持强一致性事物的底层数据库，就能解决高层级的业务容错问题。
[S02] 难道不是吗？数据库内部的事务机局势却很强，它能保证哪怕服务器突然断电，数据库内部的数据也不会出现一半写成功，一半失败的窘境。
[S01] 那挺好啊。
[S02] 但是它保护不了通信链路。你想象一下，数据库完美的处理了你的扣款，并且把支付成功的消息发送出去了。
[S01] 然后呢？
[S02] 但是这个消息在穿过城市基站到达你手机的过程中，呃，你的WIFI突然断了。
[S01] 也就是说，在数据库的世界里，交易已经完美结束了，钱已经扣了。但在我的手机屏幕上，我看到的还是网络超时请重试。
[S02] 是的，这时候你会怎么做？你很自然的会狂点重试，对吧？
[S01] 绝对会狂点啊，心里慌吗？
[S02] 从SERVER的角度来看，这是一个全新的请求，数据当然会理所当然的开启一个新的事物，再扣你一次钱。
[S01] 哇，那底层基础建设在这一刻真的毫无用处了。
[S02] 没错，为了解决这个问题，资料里引入了一个诞生于一九八四年的伟大理念，叫做端到端原则。
[S01] 等一下，一九八四年那个时候连万维网都没发明吧，大家还在用软盘呢。一个那么古老的理论，怎么解决我今天在五G网络下的双重扣款问题？
[S02] 虽然技术变了，但原理是完全相通的。端到端原则的核心思想是不要指望中间的通信链路或者底层的基础建设，能替你把所有问题都解决了。
[S01] 那靠谁？
[S02] 真正的可靠性必须在通信的两端，也就是你的手机客户端和最终的数据库来建立。
[S01] 那具体到我狂点购买按钮的场景到底怎么解决呢？
[S02] 答案是由你的手机客户端在第一次准备付款时，立刻生成一个全球唯一的操作标识符。我们通常叫它REQUESTID,比如一长串乱码。
[S01] 哦，我明白了，因为这个唯一的ID是我的手机生成的，所以哪怕我因为恐慌狂点了一百次提交，发送出去的一百个请求里，带着的其实全都是同一个REQUESTID.
[S02] 精确，这个独一无二的ID会一路穿透网络到达SERVER,最终随着扣款指令写进数据库里。
[S01] 然后数据库怎么处理？
[S02] 我们在数据层面，针对这个ID设置一个唯一性约束。第一笔扣款成功时，这个ID就被记录在案了。当因为你狂点而产生的第二、第三次请求，带着相同的ID抵达时，数据库一看
[S01] 数据会会说，诶，这个ID刚刚处理过了。
[S02] 没错，它就会直接把旧的成功结果返回给你，而绝对不会再次执行扣款。这就实现了一个非常优雅的数学属性，叫做幂等性。
[S01] 幂等性，这听起来像是个挺吓人的学术名字，但结合你刚才说的，这不就像是按电梯按钮吗？
[S02] 怎么说？
[S01] 比如我等电梯的时候心急，狂按了十次向下键，但电梯系统很聪明，它知道这十次按键的目的都是一样的，它绝对不会因此派十部电梯来接我。不管我按一次还是十次，最终的结果都是一样的。
[S02] 哎呀，这个比喻非常绝妙，这就是幂等性，用REQUESTID实现幂等性，成功保住了你的钱包。
[S01] 钱包保住了，松了一口气。
[S02] 但是既然你提到了抢演唱会门票，我们如果顺着分拆系统的思路继续往下推演，你会发现一个更棘手的挑战。
[S01] 哦，我的钱包保住了，难道票保不住？
[S02] 设想一下，既然我们为了极致的性能把系统拆分了，不再使用那种让所有流程排队等待的全局同步锁。那么系统怎么知道这件商品到底还有没有货？
[S01] 对啊，如果没有同步锁检查库存的话。
[S02] 如果只剩最后一张票，你在北京点击了购买，另一个人在上海同一毫秒也点击了购买，没有了实时的同步锁检查，系统不是会把同一张票卖给你们两个人吗？
[S01] 确实啊，如果为了性能放弃了实时确认，系统不就全乱套了吗？卖出两张不存在的票，这听起来像是个巨大的灾难。
[S02] 这里我们需要进行一次概念上的降维打击。资料中特别指出，人们往往混淆了两个极其重要的词，及时性和完整性。
[S01] 及时性和完整性，这两者不是一码事吗？如果不及时，怎么保证数据完整？
[S02] 资料里有一句金句，完美的概括了它们的区别。这句话是违反及时性，叫最终一致性，违反完整性，叫永无一致性。
[S01] 哇，违反及时性叫最终一致性，违反完整性叫永无一致性。这句话有点东西，所以到底怎么区分这两个概念？
[S02] 及时性是指你此刻立刻马上就能看到系统绝对最新的状态。比如你刚才要求的系统必须在毫秒级内绝对确定，没人跟你抢这张票。
[S01] 那完整性呢？
[S02] 而完整性是指业务逻辑的底线没有被破坏。比如钱没有凭空消失，账目最终是能对上的。
[S01] 明白了。
[S02] 你要知道，现实世界的商业活动其实根本就不需要完美的及时性。
[S01] 仔细想想还真是这么回事。哎，你这么一说，我明白了，最典型的例子不就是航空公司吗？他们几乎总是超售机票。
[S02] 没错，非常典型的例子。
[S01] 一架飞机明明只有一百个物理座位，他们偏偏要卖一百零五张票，他们绝对不是不知道库存不够，而是为了对冲有人退票的风险，刻意在及时性上撒了谎。
[S02] 完全正确。航空公司仓库发错货，还有银行允许你的信用卡暂时透支，这些全都是现实中主动放弃及时性的例子。
[S01] 都是为了保证业务运转。
[S02] 如果我们为了保证绝对的实时的不超卖，强行要求全球几十个数据中心在同一毫秒内锁定状态，那成本极其昂贵不说，而且只要有一根光缆被挖断，整个系统就会瞬间瘫痪，谁也买不了票。
[S01] 瘫痪的代价太大了。那如果不加锁，导致真的超卖了，这一百零五个人全都跑来登机了。现实世界的解法是什么？总不能让系统崩溃吧。
[S02] 当然不是现实的解法，是引入补偿性事物。
[S01] 所以到底什么是补偿性事物？听起来很高深。
[S02] 哈哈，其实放到航空公司的例子里，所谓的补偿性事物，说白了就是写一封道歉信，然后塞钱补偿。
[S01] 啊，对，如果超售了，机场广播就会响。各位旅客非常抱歉，本次航班超员有没有哪位愿意改先下一班？我们为你免费升舱，并补偿您五千块钱加一晚五星级酒店。
[S02] 就是这个逻辑，话糙理不糙。在绝大多数情况下，道歉加上补偿的成本远远低于让整个系统保持绝对同步锁定的成本。
[S01] 是的，更远远低于系统瘫痪流失的收入。
[S02] 是的，我们可以先乐观的接受大量高并发的订单，保证用户极其顺滑的购票体验，然后在后端异步的去验用库存。
[S01] 发现不够了再处理。
[S02] 对，如果发现超卖了，没关系，启动补偿流程，给用户发一封道歉邮件退款，再大方的送一张无门槛代金券。这种架构在资料中被称为无协商数据系统。
[S01] 所以这一切到底意味着什么呢？这意味着现代数据系统就是能扛住双十一，或者是那种超级巨星演唱会带来的恐怖流量狂风，恰恰是因为它放弃了完美的实时同步。
[S02] 说的很对。
[S01] 它允许子弹飞一会儿，允许短暂的混乱，但它通过端到端的REQUESTID保证了你绝对不会被多扣钱。又通过后端的补偿性事物，保证了最终的逻辑闭环。在极度混乱中，它依然守住了完整性的底线。这种工程哲学简直太有魅力了。
[S02] 总结得非常透彻。我们现在拥有了一个容错、高并发、靠异步事件流动，甚至靠道歉来润滑的弹性系统。但是作为架构师，我们千万不要高兴的太早。
[S01] 怎么了？还有隐患？
[S02] 在资料的最后部分还潜伏着最后一个幽灵。如果这一切赖以运行的软件代码本身就有bug呢？
[S01] 这正是我在看资料时倒吸一口凉气的地方。资料里明确提到，即便是像MYSQL和POSTRESCUE这样久经考验，被全球一万家公司作为基石使用的成熟数据库，居然也会在某些极端情况下未能正确维护唯一约束，或者产生隔离级别的BUG.
[S02] 是的，底层的基石有时也会动摇。
[S01] 这太可怕了。如果连数据库底层都在撒谎，我们到底还能相信什么？
[S02] 结论非常冷酷，那就是永远不要盲目信任任何系统，必须坚持信任，但要合适。
[S01] 信任，但要合适。
[S02] 你要知道，硬件会老化，内存位会因为宇宙射线发生翻转，网络包会损坏，软件永远存在未知的BUG数据损坏不是会不会发生的问题，而是合适发生的问题。
[S01] 绝对会发生。
[S02] 这就要求我们的系统不仅要能正常运行，还必须能够被高效的审计。
[S01] 审计，你是说像财务查账一样，派几个人去把数据库里的表一行一行对一遍吗？那怎么查得过来？
[S02] 机器世界的审计要比那严谨而且高效得多。也就是为什么我们前面提到的事件溯源日志如此重要。
[S01] 哦，就是那个记录所有动作的日志。
[S02] 的，只允许追加，永远不准修改。
[S01] 就像飞机的黑匣子。
[S02] 绝妙的比喻就是黑匣子，它忠实地记录了所有状态变更的来龙去脉。
[S01] 我明白了，所以如果有一天账目真的对不上了，我完全不需要去猜测，我只需要把那段不可变的事件日志提取出来，像播唱录像带一样，把历史操作一帧一帧的重新跑一遍，我立刻就能知道到底是哪一次扣款动作，或者哪个版本的代码出了岔子。
[S02] 不仅如此，为了防止连底层的硬盘储存都悄悄发生损坏，像HDFS或者亚马逊S三这样的大规模储存系统，在后台都有进程，在不知不觉的持续读取和校验自己的数据块。
[S01] 连硬盘都不信任。
[S02] 更有趣的是，资料中预测未来的企业数据系统可能会越来越多的借鉴BLOCKCHAIN底层运用的一些密码学技术。
[S01] 等等，BLOCKCHAIN那不是用来炒币的吗？怎么跟咱们的企业级数据库扯上关系了？
[S02] 哈哈哈，抛开加密货币的炒作不谈，BLOCKCHAIN底层有些技术简直天生就是为了审计而生的。比如默克尔数和证书透明性机制。
[S01] 必须打断一下，什么是默克尔数？能不能别用密码学名词吓唬我？哈哈哈。
[S02] 没问题，没问题。你想象一棵非常庞大的家谱树，这棵树最底层的叶子就是你的一条条交易记录。
[S01] 好的，树叶是记录。
[S02] 如果有人或者是某个BUG篡改了其中一片叶子上的数据，这片叶子的颜色就会改变，而这会立刻导致连着它的树枝变色。
[S01] 连锁反应。
[S02] 树枝变色又会导致更粗的树干变色，最终导致整棵树的根部发生变色。
[S01] 哇，所以这意味着什么呢？
[S02] 这意味着作为审计人员，我根本不需要去检查几百万片叶子，我只需要看一眼树根，只要树根的颜色没变，我就能在数学上百分之一百确定底层的所有数据都没有被任何人任何BUG篡改过。
[S01] 太聪明了。
[S02] 这种技术能让你在不使用极其昂贵和慢的分布式共识协议的前提下，极其高效的验证数据的真实性。
[S01] 哇，这太绝妙了。今天的信息量确实很大，但内在的逻辑又如此自洽，让我们来为你梳理一下这趟旅程的核心收获吧。
[S02] 好的。
[S01] 下次当你坐在颠簸的地铁里，发现手机APP依然能顺滑使用时，或者当你在狂欢节抢购屏幕提示网络异常，但你不再惊慌的担心被扣两次钱时，又或者当你收到一封标题为非常抱歉，由于库存不足，已为你全额退款并赠送一张五十元带薪券的邮件时，
[S02] 你肯定会心一笑。
[S01] 没错，你会心一笑。因为你现在知道了，这并不是系统快要崩溃了。恰恰相反，这是现代数据流架构正在通过读写路径分离，端到端原则和补偿性事物在完美优雅的运作着，没有什么是完美的，但工程师们设计出了一套在混乱和错误中依然坚韧无比的系统。
[S02] 是的，从打破全能数据库的深化，将庞然大物拆分成由事件日志驱动的组件，到接受异步与最终一致性，用补偿机制替代死板的同步锁，再到不盲信任何系统，引入黑箱子般的事件溯源和密码学审计。这一切都在向我们展示一种拥抱变化，在不完美中寻找稳健的工程哲学。
[S01] 总结得太好了。那么在今天这次探索的最后，我想给你，也就是屏幕前的你留一个资料中没有直接给出答案，但基于我们今天的逻辑自然延伸出的问题，供你自己在夜深渐认时慢慢决绝。
[S02] 哦，什么问题？
[S01] 今天我们学到，为了保证系统的完整性和完美的可审计性，最前沿的做法是采用事件溯源，也就是记录每一条不可贬的日志，让系统永远不会忘记你做过的任何一个动作。
[S02] 确实是这样设计的。
[S01] 但是请你设想一下，在今天这个极其看重个人隐私，许多国家甚至已经立法保护公民被遗忘权的时代。如果你在数字世界里的每一次CLICK,每一次搜索，每一笔交易都是一条永远无法篡改，永远无法被真正物理删除的事件流。
[S02] 这确实引人深思。
[S01] 那么我们究竟该如何在工程师们孜孜以求的绝对的数据完整性和现实世界中人类的隐私权之间找到那个平衡点呢？当我们设计出一个拥有绝对记忆的完美系统时，它对人类来说究竟是堡垒还是牢笼？
[S02] 这是一个非常深刻的哲学困境，也是技术发展到今天必须面对的现实，非常值得每一个人，尤其是未来的系统设计者去深思。
[S01] 没错，回到一开始阿奎那的那句话，船终究是要出海的，无论前方是风暴、暗礁还是道德的迷雾。感谢你参与我们今天的深度解析，期待下次与你共同探索新的知识边界。我们下次见。
[S02] 下次见。